Speaker 1: There are some Republicans already
endorsing Donald Trump for 2024.
Donald Trump hasn't even announced he's running
in 2024.
And one of the things Pat and I spoke about
yesterday on the award winning bonus show
oh, the.
Speaker 2: Bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: Is that this 2024 presidential
election may maybe the most interesting and
unique presidential election I will have ever
covered, and probably that I'll ever have
been alive for.
Think about what we could be heading towards
that I have been alive for so far.
I want to, you know, in the future, anything
could happen.
We could have the incumbent president, Joe
Biden, not run for reelection.
The sitting vice president, Kamala Harris,
trying for the nomination and losing it potentially.
She's very unpopular right now.
That's just a fact.
It's not my opinion.
I mean, Kamala Harris is perfectly fine person.
She's just not very popular right now.
So you could have Biden say, I'm not running
for reelection.
Harris saying I am running.
And Democratic voters might choose someone
else.
So the sitting VP might lose the Democratic
nomination.
On the Republican side, you could have a former
president, one term president, Donald Trump,
who lost was removed from office trying to
become the nominee.
That alone would be unique and he may also
lose.
It's not obvious that Donald Trump would win.
He probably would win based on current polling.
But Ron DeSantis is surging every two weeks,
every week or two.
Ron DeSantis is doing better and better in
2024.
Betting markets that I can't think of another
time when that's happened.
Sitting president doesn't run VP.
He tries for the nomination up against a one
term president, also trying for the nomination.
So Trump not even running.
Some Republicans already endorsing him.
Here's Jim Jordan, a horrible person by any
stretch of the imagination saying what we
need is Trump back in the White House.
Video So yeah, but this will not change until
Donald Trump is back in the White House and
we get a commander in chief who knows how
to lead.
But you're absolutely right, hundreds of pilots.
Okay.
So Jim Jordan says we need Trump back in the
White House.
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert or Boebert, she
has put up a Trump 2024 flag at Shooter's
Grill, which I guess is her restaurant in
Colorado or something.
So she's already on Trump 2024.
Marco Rubio has said if Trump runs, then yeah,
I would support him.
Here's an interview from a few months ago
for Marco Rubio, for Florida Republican senator.
Speaker 3: A senator added that he's confident
the state's 2022 election cycle is secure.
Looking ahead to 2024, I asked Senator Rubio
if he would support Donald Trump for another
term as president.
Yeah, look, if Donald Trump is going to run.
Speaker 2: For president 2024, he'll be the
Republican nominee.
And of course, I would support him in that.
I mean, we're a long ways off from that.
What's going to happen between now and then?
Speaker 1: True.
So there's Marco Rubio who says he would support
Trump if Trump were the nominee.
And then, I mean, this is just it's almost
a little weird.
Even Mitch McConnell, the Senate now minority
leader, former majority leader, a Republican
who has said so many negative things about
Trump, has clashed with Trump when it comes
to the January six riots.
Trump has been attacking McConnell for so
long.
Even Mitch McConnell says, yeah, I mean, if
he's the nominee, I would support him.
Speaker 2: If that was allowed to happen between
now and 24, I've got at least four members
that I think are planning on running for president,
plus some focus on governors and others.
There's no incumbent should be a wide open
race and fun for you all to cover.
If the president was the party's nominee,
would you support him?
Oh, the nominee of the party?
Absolutely.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So for all the negative things that Mitch
McConnell has said about Trump and how horrifying
Trump's actions were around January six, all
of it.
Oh, yeah, he's the nominee.
Of course I'll support him.
I guess it sounds like there's really no one
that Mitch McConnell wouldn't support over
a Democrat if they were the party's nominee.
And then Republican senator from South Carolina,
Tim Scott, says, of course, this is from a
few months ago.
Of course, he would support Donald Trump if
Donald Trump runs again in 2024.
Now, on the other side of this, the other
interesting component to this is that there's
a growing list of Republicans who are not
going to be supporting Donald Trump in 2024.
And there's kind of three buckets of Republicans.
And this may change as things go forward.
There's the people already supporting Trump
2024, even though he's not a candidate.
There's those who are just waiting probably
to kind of put their finger to the wind and
see, does it look like the party wants Trump
again, or is it looking like it's going to
be DeSantis or what?
But, you know, they're kind of fairweather
Trump supporters.
And then you've got the people who have said,
I am not supporting Donald Trump ever again.
Of course, this includes Liz Cheney and Adam
Kinzinger, the two Republicans who are on
the January six committee.
But a former Trump ally, Arkansas Governor
Asa Hutchinson, has said he's not going to
be supporting Trump or at least he may run
against Trump.
He may run for the 2024 Republican nomination.
Mitt Romney, who has said, I believe if Trump
runs, he will win the nomination, but he would
have to do it without Mitt Romney's support.
And there are others as well.
So shaping up and I know that this is very
unlike me, you know, in 2012.
Um, when people were saying well known in
2013, when people were asking me questions
about the 2016 presidential, I said, we've
got to get past the 2014 midterm first in
2017, when there was so much discussion about
2020.
I said, We've got to deal with the 2018 midterm
first.
This is an unusual situation.
So much of the midterms relates directly to
2024, particularly when Republicans are trying
to use the 2022 midterms to take control of
more state election systems so that then they
can give 24 to their nominee.
No matter who wins in the actual voting and
on and on and on.
So this is a unique situation in that the
22 and 24 elections are inextricably linked.
And as I mentioned at the top of the segment.
24 is looking like it could be one of the
wildest and most unusual situations I've ever
covered or even lived through.
I mean, you think about 1992.
Okay.
Yeah.
Bill Clinton defeated one term George H.W.
Bush.
Not the most common scenario, but nothing
compared to sitting president.
Doesn't run VP tries, maybe loses.
Former one term president tries to run, maybe
wins, maybe loses.
That's wild.
And I expect it to be absolutely insane.
We're going to take a quick, quick break.
We're going to come back.
We're going to examine a radical Republican's
track record of gaffes and try to ascertain,
is she really?
This dumb.
I mean, I don't know any other way to say
it.
Is she really this dumb?
Remember that Saturday night?
Donald Trump will be in Alaska trying to damage
Lisa murkowski.
Republican Senator Lisa murkowski, his reelection
campaign, he doesn't like her.
He calls her a rhino.
We will be live with that on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook.
I hope you'll join me.
But let's take a quick break.
Plenty more still to come today.